euh aujourd'hui hommage national aux
victimes du 7 octobre 75 % des Français
estiment que les députés LFI n'avaient
pas leur place êtes-vous d'accord bien
sûr qu'il n'avent pas leur place les
députés la fille il n leur place nulle
part d'ailleurs d'ailleurs quand ils
sont arrivés dans la cour des Invalides
forcément ils sont fait siffler regardez
Gill je sais que ça va te faire mal de
voir tes amis comme ça ils se font
siffler ça te fait du mal hein pas mes
amis c'est tes amis
regarde je suis évidemment triste que ça
se passe comme ça je pense que c'est un
moment où on doit au contraire être dans
la
Concorde réunion et ne pas profiter de
cet instant pour faire des polémiques
qui en plus sont basé sur beaucoup de
désinformation et et de calomnie c'est
le seul voilà donc on parlait de la
fille bon en tout cas lui Emer Caron en
tout cas il a eu le courage de parler au
micro après après je dire non mais les
gars non mais on parlait d'un des sens
mais eux c'est eux c'est
alors ils vont ils vont plus loin
toujours plus haut mais eux c'est
toujours plus loin toujours plus haut
dans l'IND des sens eux dans le ridicule
c'est incroyable al d'Urs il y a une
petite altercation entre meilleer Habib
et manuel bonpard regardez ça vous fait
de la peine de voir votre ami comme ça
regardez pas mes amis si c'est vos
amis
[Musique]
ouis ah ouais ouais ouais ce qui est fou
vous avez vu et c'est vrai
que c'est incroyable cette séquence elle
est incroyable parce qu' elle veut dire
beaucoup de choses he sûr c'est fou
c'est Jordan mardella il se fait tacler
pour ça parce qu'il a fait la bise à
ouais Jordan mardella derrière oui non
mais c'est incroyable cette séquence
parce que elle est elle est c'est un
truc de fou qui on nous aurait dit il y
a y a quelques années que voilà ça on
aurait cette séquence c'est complètement
fou mais la LFI c'est littéralement
disqualifié disqualifié de la société
pour moi je vous le dis parun qui a une
face c'est Rufin c'est le seul qui est
sorti de l'eau qui a dit on peut pas
aller contre la volonté de parents qu'on
pe en non mais r r c'est le seul c'est
le seul qui sort sur les du jeu
d'ailleurs il devrait il devrait monter
son parti parce que il y a plein de gens
qui le suivrai je pense que c'est une
bonne alternative à la gauche R qui est
quelqu'un
de discernement exactement qui qui et
ben en plus il prend toujours le
contrepied enfin il est en fait il est
plutôt juste le reste le reste c'est
quand même une bande de franchement de
pitre hein excusez-moi Gilles Verdez
donc Gilles Verdez on va démarrer par
vous 75 % des Français estiment qu'ils
n'aient pas leur place
à cet hommage national vous dites NON je
comprends même pas comment on peut dire
non quand les familles des victimes
disent on veut pas les voir c'est comme
si tu vas un anniversaire on dit on veut
pas de
voir Com Com ce gar là mais comment tous
les jours il peut aller aussi plus loin
dans la défense
des des gens qui sont indéfendables dans
la défense de l'indéfendable g ver va
encore plus loin tous les jours on a vu
un instant ce qu'il nous a dit là
continue et là est-ce que juste voir les
autres vous dites tous oui je su person
P dire non bien entendu je vois même pas
comment on peut dire nonit je ne sais
pas comment on peut dire non quand la
famille des victimes a dit on veut pas
vous voir on veut pas vous voir mais
g mais à un moment même François Ruffin
qui fait partie de la LFI même lui il a
dit choses mais ils ont pas de face non
mais vraiment alors on va laisser parler
après parce que j'ai envie de savoir
quels sont ses arguments il les a déjà
donné dans face à noun je crois qu'il en
a d'utres maintenant par que il peut
toujours trouver de nouvels trucs dans
sa botte secrète de l'indéfendable donc
il a une botte secrète de l'indéfendable
je sais pas de quoi il se nourrit le
soir à mon avis avoir une potion magique
hein non mais voilà et ben écoutez tiens
qui veut qui veut Raymon non moi je
pense qu'il faut respecter ce qu' a dit
la famille la famille dit on veut pas de
la LFI parce qu'ils ont refusé de
condamner donc ça sert à rien de venir
for ça en plus ils viennent et en plus
comme Emer Caron ils viennent au micro
ouais c'est dommage c'est regrettable
tel comport pomp poman fallait pas venir
c'est tout tu l'aurais pas eu ce
comportement là tu aurais pas eu les
sifflets tu serais resté chez toi
tranquillement voilà et Jean-Luc
méanchon il a pas été il va jamais lui
quand on parle d'un sondage s'il y avait
Marine Le Pen et Jean-Luc Mélenchon au
second tour un sondage là a priori 68
Marine Le Pen 32 ml Mélenchon oua c'est
c'est fou oui non non c'est j'ai j'ai
j'ai vais laissé parler les camarades si
la famille te dit tu vas pas normalement
tu as une dessence tu as une face tu te
dis voilà j'y vais pas c'est un hommage
je je laisse les autres je rest chez moi
et je tweete et ils sont très forts pour
teeter pourquoi ils ont pas t je
comprends pas après le comportement
qu'ils ont eu mais faites-vous tout
petit ou bien
même à la limite assumer jusqu'au bout
mais soyez pas hypocrite à venir là pour
pour faire chier tout le monde en plus
cétait c'était une marque c'était un
hommage un hommage quand il y a des gens
que tu as pas envie de voir déjà tu vas
mettre une sale ambiance non mais c'est
insupportable c'est c'est vraiment je
vous dis c'est vraiment faire chier le
monde ENIT ont gâché l'homage
ENIT oui mais on avait pas envie de voir
on av pas envie de les voir sur qu'
aurait pas de caméra ça ét intimité des
familles serait pas venu là c'est
seulement par événement
r vitimisation en disant la
désinformation qu'il sont victimes du
systèmeon dit on n pas
compris parce que c'est aussi une
posture politique de cornis oui mais les
Français ne sont pas DUP tout au long de
la séquence les mecs ont confondu cause
palestinenne et cause du Hamas sils ont
réellement évolué que ma pan exclu soudé
danielon et tous ceux qui ont dérapé
aujourd'hui c'est un coup de com un coup
de com et qui a échoué car français ne
sont plus dupes et c'est à cause de ces
gensl que Marine Le Pen est aussi aussi
haute dans les sondages et qu'elle est
au portes du pouvoir elle là F c'est
l'un des S c'est respect incarné et je
dire et et c'est des gens comme comme
Gill Verdez aussi qui font que R
aujourd'hui est devenu le le B
le responsable de parti
oui ah bien sûr en voulant pas prendre
les problèmes des Français à bras le cor
en disant oh on peut rien faire c'est et
ben tu tu tu tu pousses les gens à voter
pour pour des gens qui eux onont les
couilles de faire quelque
chose oui qu'est-ce qu'il y a j'avais
jamais entendu ça alors il
pe deè fois je redire les yeux dans les
yeux que je suis responsable de la
montée des voies en
partie sû oui en disant en disant qu'il
faut rien faire qu'il faut laisser les
gens qui g les gens qui vivent de la
cistana faut rien faire maisil y en a
pas il y en a pas fa les squatters faut
les laisser ils sonts sont pas
de qui sont cambriolés ah ben non fa les
fout comme ça mais non c'était toujours
comme ça bah à force de vouloir rien
régler g veulent régler les choses et
ben du coup ils prennent les choses en
main et ils descendent dans la rue et
ils votent en conséquence
voilà'ava je t'avais dit l'autre jour
que tu étais une Vérus sur le gland je
m'en excuse c'est c'est pas beau en fait
un Furon clul pire que ça un f
clulaire non c'est ma
chute non mais anal politique hein comme
beaucoup de Français il pe aller sur les
Grand Radi fr j'ai même pas compris j'ai
un fion de cocu c'est ça que fon cocu un
F en plus c'est
[Applaudissements]
sourd les gars stop stop stop on arrête
on arrête on arrête comme beaucoup de
comme beaucoup de Français à force
d'écouter Gilles verd et de regarder les
actes de la France insoumises
aujourd'hui on a bien plus peur de
Mélenchon que de Marine Le Pen et
t'emporte tuemporte la responsabilité
to c'est vrai mais ah mais alors mais
non mais la défense la défense elle est
extrêmement ténue parce qu'ils ont été
nuls de bout en bout moi j'ai condamné
le fait qu'il ne proclame pas les la
barbarie du Hamas comme un acte
terroriste mais là ils sont obligés d'y
aller même si vous pouvez pas vous
souscrire à un hommage national quand
vous êtes élu au Parlement s'ils n'y
vont pas ils se mettent en dehors de la
République c'est impossible il faut y
aller il faut y
aller faut y aller non mais il faut y
aller
vouses oigé d' aller je comprends la
douleur des
famill ils ont du mal à défiler dans la
LTE contre
l'antisémmeme droite
qui enant que non non c'était pas
c'était pas sous les G du président de
la République et
Françis bas par vous vous souscrivez à
ça av de assemées de présidents des
assemées la Haute Assemblée le
sénère par
derrièreoss plus dans la républque
voil je peux pas entendre ce que tu dis
je peux pas entendre c'est pas possible
mais comment tu trouves des arguments
comme ça qui les donne mais c'est pas
des arguments dans ma tête ma tête qui
doit tu es sûr tuas pas coupé tes
cheveux j'ai l'IM C attaqué non mais
vous pouvez pas vous souscrire à ça si
vous n'y allez pas vous entérinez le
fait que vous n'êtes plus dans la
représent
sonjà
républain il aurait été tout à l'URE
honneur par exemple de faire une lettre
et de dire voilà nous nous aurions
souhaité y être mais malheureusement
noppos on fait que on a blessé des
FAM et donc on aurait pu ENF sign par
GRP et de voil la représentation aurit
comm je je vais l juste beaucoup de
ractions qui qui arrive sur toi Gill
pardon mais c'est insupportable ce que
dit Gill en donnant raison à la LF sur
leur présence Gill insulte la volonté
des familles des victimes c'est vrai
qu'il y en a énormément comme ça de de
réactions comment tu comment tu tu tu
réponds à ça mais on peut pas comprendre
la douleur indiciible des famille je
comprends totalement que re écoute ce
genre de phrase pour dire après la LF
avait place à l'hommage je veux pas les
entendre dis parce que c'est pas c'est
c'est pas concevable tu ne peux pas dire
dans une phrase la douleur ressent les
familles ressent les familles est
indiscible et dans l'autre phrase oui la
France insoumise avait sa place à
l'hommage c'est pas possible tu vois
c'est pas possible ces deux phrase en
anagonisme total tu peux pas dire ça tu
peux pas cononner que des gens apportent
de la douleur des gens qui ont déjà
énormément de douleur et c'est ce qui s
pass tu peux pas dire ça et dire dans la
même phrase alors que la famille des
victimes dit on ne veut pas voir la
France insoumise dire oui la France
insoumise doit être à l'hommage donc
Gill Merz c'est obsè c'est pas possible
mais pourquoi alors à ce momentl obsè
non mais même ce que tu dis parce que tu
dis une phrase et derrière en fait tu
dis t tu dis tout le contraire non mais
j'essaie d'expliquer le fait qu'ils y
soitent allés ils y sont allés Cyril non
mais ils y sont allés donc on essaie de
comprendre pourquoi ils sont allés parce
que c'est des guign non parce que vous
ne pouvez pas vous souscrire à un
hommage national personne le fait jamais
c'est
impossible dis c'est pour ça je te dis
qu'ils auraient pu per leur absence par
un communiqué officiel en disant nous
aurions souhaité mais nous savons que
notre présence aurait p et donc
voilà je voudrais juste dire un truc je
voudrais juste dire un truc sur sur les
familles des victimes qui ont été d'une
grandeur incroyable voilà je vous le dis
et c'est ça que je retiens à la parce
qu'ils sont venus et là LFI ils sont
encore une fois passé tes amis pour des
cons une fois de plus et ne me dis pas
que ce sont pas tes amis tu les
défendrais pas autant voilà et les
familles des victimes elles ont été
d'une classe incroyable je peux vous
dire et elles ont mis la LI devant leurs
contradiction et devant leurs erreurs et
je peux te dire aujourd'hui moi si
j'étais membre de la LFI que j'avais été
là-bas aujourd'hui l'après-midi je peux
te dire que je me j'aurais du mal à me
regarder dans une glace et et à me
regarder dans un miroir et continuer à
faire des tweets et continuer à faire
les beau à l'Assemblée nationale ou sur
les réseaux sociaux si j'étais eux je me
ferai tout petit petit petit petit petit
hein je peux vous dire et tes amis tu
peux leur dire tiens si tu peux les le
faire passer un message qu'ils se fasse
tout petit petit parce qu'ils sont
passés pour des cons et le comportement
des familles des victimes les amis plus
bacèes voilà je te le dis et les
familles des victimes elles ont été la
classe des familles des VI victime on
montré on montré je vais te dire l'IND
des sens de la France insoumise et la
honte qui est la France insoumise en ce
moment pour la France c'est une honte je
te dis et tes amis sont une honte ce
sont tes amis voilà donc arrête de dire
ce sont pas tes amis amis mes amis je
dirais c'est mes amis c'est pas mes
amis je suis en désaccord avec eux
làdessus depuis le début mais il ne
pouvait pas ne pas y aller c'est
impossible pourquoi il sont pas ven à la
marche contre l'antisémitisme c'est la
prés de l'É nationale ils sont députés
c'est la présid de
nation sur les mots
[__] pas qu'il est d'une malhonnté
comme ils y sont allés en méisant la
cause ils y sont allés en se bouchant le
nez ils y sont allés sans vraiment de
conviction c'est ce que tu dis là vous
parlez pour êre dans ils y sont allés
parce que ils sont obligés d'y aller
encire le
le les téléspectateurs voilà 84,5%
d'accord ou hocrite
plusz on rrouve dans un instant
incroyable à tout de
suite